einigung nach zähen ringen in brüssel
verständigen sich die eu regierungschefs
auf das milliardenschwere corona
hilfspaket attentäter von halle vor
gericht neun monate nachdem
antisemitisch motivierten anschlag auf
eine synagoge zeigt der städter stefan
bald keine reue und große not in indien
starker monsun und überschwemmungen
verschärfen die korona krise dramatisch
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten um 19 uhr die vom
sport hat wieder norbert lehmann
transformiert und diesmal können wir mit
einem ergebnis in brüssel beginnen die
27 eu staaten haben es im morgengrauen
doch noch geschafft sich
zusammenzuraufen und auf das größte haus
als und finanzpaket der geschichte zu
einigen
alle sind erleichtert doch der weg dahin
war steinig und quälend fast 100 stunden
wurde erbittert gestritten was
beschlossen wurde fasst axel conrad
zusammen
die gewaltige summe von 1800 milliarden
euro braucht die eu für die aufgaben der
nächsten jahre
750 milliarden davon umfasst der chor
ohne aufbau vor
besonders umstritten dabei die höhe der
nicht zu rückzahlbaren zuschüsse 390
milliarden euro werden bereitgestellt
in erster linie für staaten deren
wirtschaft besonders unter der krise
leidet beispiel italien bedingungen die
wirtschaft dieser länder muss reformiert
werden
die restlichen 360 milliarden aus dem
aufbau fonds fließen als kredite die eu
länder machen damit zum ersten mal
gemeinsame schulden die tilgung soll
auch über neue einnahmen erfolgen
beispiele eine abgabe auf plastikmüll
und eine digital steuer
verhandelt wurde auch der haushalt bis
20 27 er umfasst 1000 74 milliarden euro
daraus werden programme für bauern
regionen oder unternehmen finanziert
doch auch das eu parlament muss noch
zustimmen
die staats und regierungschefs der 27
erhalten jedenfalls viel lob vor allem
wohl weil ihnen überhaupt die einigung
nach so viel streit gelungen ist doch
das hatte seinen preis emotional und
inhaltlich da blieb manches auf der
strecke wie die absicht eu gelder an
rechtsstaatlichkeit zu binden
glück war port über die letzten 24
stunden des brüsseler marathons
bis zuletzt musste der ratsvorsitzende
michelle bangen so geladen war
streckenweise die stimmung so verbittert
der kampf um milliarden
am ende fand man doch den kompromiss
erleichterung auch bei bundeskanzlerin
merkel die ein scheitern unter deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft verhindern konnte
wir haben damit die weichen für die
finanziellen grundlagen der europäischen
union für die nächsten sieben jahre
gestellt und gleichzeitig eine antwort
auf die größte krise seit bestehen der
europäischen union gegeben
in form des wideraufbau fonds die
kanzlerin und staatspräsident marco
wollten mit dem fonds ein zeichen setzen
dass europa handlungsfähig ist und mit
starken mitteln auf die korona krise
antworten kann also mit oli das war ein
gipfel mit historischen folgen wir haben
zum ersten mal die möglichkeit
geschaffen gemeinsam kredite aufzunehmen
dort rannte onkel heftig umstritten
waren die verteilung der hilfsgelder
sowie auflagen für die empfängerländer
die niederlande österreich und die
scandinavia stimmten erst zu nachdem
ihnen bei den beitragszahlungen zum
haushalt größere rabatte eingeräumt
wurden diese rabatte die auch
deutschland gewährt werden sollen eine
übermäßige belastung der nettozahler
verringern
die kommission wollte alle rabatte
abschaffen stattdessen werden sie jetzt
erhöht ich bin sehr froh darüber dass
die niederlande künftig
inflationsbereinigt ungefähr genauso
viel nach brüssel überweisen werden wie
bisher ein wichtiger erfolg auch polens
regierungschef morawski und sein
ungarischer kollege opfern waren
zufrieden obwohl gewaltenteilung
pressefreiheit und minderheitenschutz in
ihren ländern zunehmend bedroht sind
erhalten sie weiter eu-gelder
finanzielle sanktionsmechanismen sollen
erst später verhandelt werden
am donnerstag berät das europaparlament
über das finanzpaket da fragen wir nach
bei stefan leifert und theo koll zuerst
bei stefan in brüssel
da sind ja ein paar kleinere staaten
sehr hart und sehr entschlossen
aufgetreten und mit erfolg hat das
deutsch französische tandem merkel makro
an autorität eingebüßt
also zumindest hat es ein kräftiges
gegengewicht bekommen denn zu den
lehrern dieses gipfels gehört auch dass
sich die machtarchitektur innerhalb der
eu vielleicht sehr nachhaltig verschoben
hat das hat mit einer allianz zu tun die
sich um den niederländer mark rutte
gegründet hat die haben nicht nur bei
diesem gipfel hier mächtig paroli
geboten sondern mit dieser allianz muss
man auch bei künftigen gipfeln wohl
rechnen dass sie sich überhaupt
formieren konnte hat mit dem brett zu
tun denn diese länder stoßen jetzt in
das machtvakuum das die briten hier auf
brüsseler bühne hinterlassen haben nicht
zuletzt aufgrund dieser allianz und des
gegenwindes stand der gipfel in den
letzten vier tagen immer wieder mal auf
der kippe
umso mehr ist diese einigung jetzt ein
erfolg trotz aller schrumpfungen beim
volumen ist der korona hilfsfonds immer
noch von einer größe die man wuchtig
nennen kann
der weg dahin war zäh und er war
streckenweise auch richtig giftig aber
unter dem strich sendet die eu aus
brüssel das signal dass sie in ihrer
größten krise eben doch zur solidarität
in der lage ist theo koll reagiert
eigentlich berlin auf das brüsseler
ergebnis und auf die gewandelte rolle
der bundeskanzlerin noch nicht so
richtig überraschen sehr stark durch die
jeweilige politische brille die linke
beklagte eine soziale schieflage und
nationalstaatliche egoismen die grünen
sind enttäuscht dass gerade in den
bereichen forschung gesundheit und klima
vor allem gekürzt wurde und die
regierungsparteien zeigen sich
überwiegend zufrieden wenn auch nicht
mit den schwach ausgefallenen regelungen
zur rechtsstaatlichkeit die werden hier
eigentlich allgemein sehr kritisch
gesehen die afg meint angela merkel
treibe deutschland in die schulden und
transfer union
damit allerdings stehen sie relativ
alleine denn der wiederaufbau von ist
zwar eine riesige aber ja einmalige
finanzleistung und eben nicht der
einstieg in euro-bonds das erklärt
übrigens auch die hohe zustimmung aus
der union für diesen ja doch sehr
kostspieligen kurs der kanzlerin
danke danke stefan aufatmen heute in
italien
hier bietet das corona virus besonders
früh und besonders heftig einer der
egoisten lockdown europas folgte
dadurch wird italiens wirtschaft dieses
jahr um mindestens elf prozent
schrumpfen schätzt die eu kommission das
nun geschnürte eu
hilfspaket lobt ministerpräsident konnte
als ehrgeizig und verspricht
umfangreiche reform tom pollock
berichtet in italiens hauptstadt rom
sind die straßen in diesen tagen so leer
wie nie mitten in der urlaubssaison
umsätze mit touristen fehlen
nach der einigung der eu hören wir hier
daher viel erleichterung aber auch
skepsis
wir sehen erst mal ob die eu gelder
überhaupt ankommen dann entscheiden wir
was das für italien bringt italien
braucht einen kulturellen und
wirtschaftlichen wandel in einer
situation sagen wir in einer ziemlich
tiefen krise
ich hoffe dass die gelder gut genutzt
werden die krise hat italien nicht nur
im tourismus hart getroffen
die industrie verzeichnete rekord
einbrüche 7,6 millionen menschen müssen
momentan mit kurzarbeit über die runden
komme die angst vor pleite wählen ist
groß und schon vor der pandemie setzten
ein schwaches wachstum und der höchste
schuldenstand in der eu dem land zu nun
kommen die korona helfen
209 milliarden euro davon 81 milliarden
als zuschüsse die nicht zurückgezahlt
werden müssen ministerpräsident suthep
konnte scheint zufrieden und verspricht
wir haben jetzt die konkrete möglichkeit
italien grüner digitaler innovativer
nachhaltiger integrativer zu machen
in schulen universitäten forschung und
infrastruktur zu investieren
doch absichtserklärungen allein dürften
nicht reichen
das risiko ist das geld zu bekommen und
es durcheinander nach dem zufallsprinzip
auszugeben die wahre herausforderung ist
dass italien zeigt dass es sich selbst
informieren
italiens regierungschef muss also
liefern
italiener und eu kritiker überzeugen der
korona deal aufbruch oder fauler
kompromiss dazu gibt es ein zdf spezial
gleich nach dieser heute -sendung infos
und hintergründe zu entscheidungen
brüssel finden sie auch online und in
unserer zdf heute knapp 150 zeugen 43
nebenkläger und 13 straftaten in der
anklageschrift in magdeburg hat ein
wichtiger prozess begonnen auf der
anklagebank der attentäter von halle an
der saale neunter oktober 2009 10 die
jüdische gemeinde feiert ihr ihren
höchsten feiertag jom kippur der schwer
bewaffnete stefan ballett versucht die
synagoge zu stürmen
es ist diese tür die er nicht aufbrechen
kann
anschließend tötet er zwei menschen den
prozess beobachtet christoph schneider
mit blaulicht wird der angeklagte am
vormittag ins land gerichtsgebäude
gebracht
aus sicherheits und platzgründen tag der
staatsschutzsenat des olg naumburg in
magdeburg die bundesanwaltschaft wirft
dem angeklagten stefan basiert unter
anderem zweifachen mord und mehrfacher
mordversuch vor
der schwer bewaffnete mann soll versucht
haben in die synagoge in halle an der
saale einzudringen
als er scheitert erschießt er in der
nähe eine 40 jahre alte frau die
zufällig mit dem fahrrad vorbei fährt
und einen 20 jährigen in einem
döner-imbiss so die anklage wie er die
taten schildert nimmt sogar die ankläger
mit
das betrifft
den doch unbändigen hass glaube ich der
deutlich geworden ist der rassismus auch
der vernichtungswille eines einzelnen
auf der anderen seite sehr schweres leid
das menschen zugefügt worden ist sie war
zum zeitpunkt des anschlags in der
synagoge in halle
christina feist sie tritt im prozess als
nebenklägerin auf ich hoffe das ist
endlich reich dass das quasi ausreichend
groß waren dann antisemitischen
übergriffen das einen echten diskurs
anzustoßen und echte maßnahmen eine
echte konsequenzen passieren die
prozesseröffnung hat schon einiges an
erkenntnissen gebracht stephan pariert
hat seine taten heute weitestgehend
gestanden
reue oder gar mitgefühl für seine opfer
zeit allerdings nicht menschenverachtend
dauerte er nur dass seine waffen oft
nicht richtig funktioniert haben und
dass er wie er sagt weiße getötet hat
statt wie geplant muslime und juden
der angeklagte wird morgen weiter
aussagen möglicherweise werden auch
schon videos der taten gezeigt
die affäre um rechtsextreme droh-mails
hat weit größere ausmaße als bisher
bekannt
wie hessens innenminister wollte wird
derzeit wegen 69 drohschreiben mit dem
kürzel nsu 2.0 ermittelt sie gingen an
personen überall im bundesgebiet in
mindestens drei fällen stammten die
daten von rechnern der hessischen
polizei andrea meuser berichtet die
opposition hatte eine sondersitzung des
innenausschusses beantragt und so musste
innenminister peter beuth überstunden
darlegen warum er bei der aufklärung der
trommel affäre nicht vorankommt
drängende fragen ausweichende antworten
das ist ein sehr sehr sehr schwer zu
ermitteln das delikt weil derjenige der
diese droh mails schreibt offensichtlich
technisch sehr gut in der lage ist seine
identität zu verschleiern auch die
frankfurter politikerin jutta ditfurth
wird immer wieder bedroht heute nach dem
3 erhielt sie so wie 13 andere erneut
eine hass mail
es war sehr präzise beschrieben wie man
mich und die 14 anderen abschlachten
möchte was damit uns passiert und es
waren auch rassistische sachen drin
es sind insgesamt 27 menschen die mit
mails bedroht verfolgt und beleidigt
werden
unter ihnen dennis hügel journalist
janine wissler politikerin weder bei
schildes anwältin und die diehl bei der
kabarettistin manche ihrer persönlichen
daten sind frei zugänglich in mindestens
drei fällen aber wurden informationen
aus dem hessischen polizei system
verwendet abgefragt auf dienstcomputern
in frankfurt und wiesbaden also ich bin
sehr betroffen und ich bin auch wütend
sag ich mal dass die ermittlung im falle
meiner kollegin frau wissler und frau
beider ganz anders lasch und lädt er
will ich mal sagen geführt wurden
polizeibeamte die auf diesen dienst
computer zutritt hatten wurden erst nach
monaten vernommen das halten wir für
einen skandal wer hat die daten
recherchiert wer die mails geschrieben
und gibt es ein rechtes netzwerk in der
hessischen polizei viele fragen sind
noch offen
eine deutsche ist in bagdad entführt
worden wie irakische sicherheitskreise
mitteilten wurde sie auf offener straße
in ein auto gezerrt und verschleppt das
auswärtige amt bildete einen krisenstab
die entführte deutsche stammt aus berlin
sie lebt seit mehreren jahren in bagdad
wo sie kunst programme leitet im irak
haben entführungen von ausländern
deutlich zugenommen
wegen der korona krise verzeichnen bund
und länder erwartungsgemäß ein dickes
minus bei den steuereinnahmen im juni
kam rund 15 milliarden weniger in die
staatskassen als im gleichen monat des
vorjahres wie das
bundesfinanzministerium mitteilte
entspricht dies einem rückgang um 19
prozent
und nun der blick auf die aktuelle
wohnanlage in deutschland sind derzeit
etwas mehr als 6200 aktive corona fälle
gemeldet
die zahl der neuinfektionen ist wieder
gestiegen
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 450 menschen mit dem
virus infiziert davor pendelte die zahl
um 400 weltweit sind inzwischen mehr als
14 millionen corona infektion bestätigt
eines der am stärksten betroffenen
länder ist nach den usa und brasilien
indien die zahl der korona fälle dort
steigt kontinuierlich an
bei mehr als eine million menschen
konnte das virus nachgewiesen werden und
es gibt mehr als 28.000 toten eine
besserung der lage ist nicht in sicht
normen odenthal berichtet jeden tag neue
rekorde die keiner will indiens corona
zahlen klettern und dabei gibt es noch
die sorge dass die offiziellen zahlen
nicht das wahre bild spiegeln wird genug
getestet zuverlässig und melden die
menschen sich wenn sie symptome haben es
gibt eine angst vor stigmatisierung
deshalb wollen sich viele nicht testen
lassen und gehen auch nicht zum arzt sie
schieben das heraus und damit auch die
mögliche behandlung viele sind
ungebildet wir müssen sie besser
informieren dass aber die krankheit
aufklären
der wirtschaftliche druck war so groß
dass die regierung lockerungen wagte nun
schlägt das virus zurück an vernunft
wird appelliert und zugleich gezweifelt
die straßen sind voll viele sind ohne
maske unterwegs so werden wir das nicht
in den griff bekommen eine million
infizierte ist furchtbar viel und wie
leicht können daraus zehn millionen
werden leicht vermutlich gerade jetzt
denn große landesteile sind vom monsun
überflutet dutzende menschen sind
gestorben häuser straßen weggespült
ganze dörfer sind verschwunden
in dieser not denken die menschen kaum
an masken und abstand diese
gesundheitsgefahr ist wohl zu abstrakt
wenn einem das wasser schon bis zum hals
steht
in lutz im nordwesten der ukraine hat
ein mann einen linienbus in seine gewalt
gebracht und mindestens 10 menschen als
geiseln genommen
nach angaben der behörden handelt es
sich um einen 44-jährigen der schwer
bewaffnet ist und sprengsätze bei sich
hat einsatzkräfte haben das stadtzentrum
abgeriegelt das motiv des täters ist
unbekannt angaben über opfer gibt es
noch nicht ja und nun zu dir norbert und
zum fußball in italien auf fußball ist
ja genau gestern war in der türkei heute
sind wir in italien denn da ist juventus
turin der meisterschaft noch näher
gerückt gestern abend den sieg über
lazio rom jubel superstar ronaldo mit
dem doppelpack und neuem rekord als
erster spieler erzielte er jeweils
mindestens 50 tore in den top-ligen von
england spanien und tagen auch mit 35
ist ronaldo ein erfolgsgarant das erste
seiner zwei tore gegen nazi umfeld nach
handspiel von bastos der portugiese
verwandelte den fälligen elfmeter ist
der 51 minute drei minuten später trifft
er erneut sein 30 history übrigens im
dreißigsten saison spielen turin führt
mit 2 0
rom bringt danach noch der
anschlusstreffer durch immobilie am sieg
der alten dame ändert das aber nichts
juve ist auf dem weg zur neunten
meisterschaft nacheinander wintersport
erfolge werden im sommer gemacht das
wissen auch die deutschen nordischen
kombinierer nach der durchwachsenen
letzten saison und vor der heim-wm in
oberstdorf gehen sie bei ihrer
vorbereitung neue wege
neue reize setzen im training die
nordischen kombinierer im windkanal die
schwächen beim springen in stärken
verwandeln heinz kuttin der österreicher
seit mai als sprungtrainer im team geht
alternative wege was macht die luft mit
mehr oder was kann ich mit der luft
machen und das kann man hier optimal
trainieren um in der kommenden wm saison
erfolgreich zu sein freuen die
kombinierer keine experimente und da
sollen sie immer gefühl entwickeln aha
ich kann mein körper sehr viel machen
wer gibt mir auch sehr viel auftrieb
der tag im windkanal für die kombinierer
ein voller erfolg mit lerneffekt und
spaß sollten wir hier auch einführen so
spaß haben wir doch ohne windkanal schön
auf das wetter bleibt zweigeteilt kühl
im norden und warm im süden
unwetterwarnungen wegen gewittern gibt
es zurzeit für bayern
mehr dazu gleich von es sind eher die
das war es von uns christian sievers
freut sich später auf sie im heute
journal und morgen ist hier an dieser
stelle barbara hahlweg für sie da jetzt
geht es weiter mit dem spezial wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
noch einen schönen abend tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter über die nordsee
kommen kompakte wolken ins land und hier
tröpfelt es etwas viel wird es aber
nicht sein
mehr schauer und auch gewitter sind auch
in der zweiten nachthälfte noch im süden
möglich zwischen den alpen und der donau
sonst bleibt es trocken die temperaturen
sinken dabei auf 6 grad im hessischen
bergland und 15 grad an den alpen die
nacht ist etwas kühler als die
vergangene
morgen dann weitere kompakte wolken im
nordwesten und einige tropfen an den
alpen weitere schauer und gewitter
möglich
aber ansonsten bleibt es dazwischen
trocken mit sonnenschein temperaturen
erreichen bis zu 29 grad im südwesten
deutschlands ganz im norden ist es
deutlich kühler mit nur 18 bis 19 grad
die nächsten tage am donnerstag gibt es
noch weitere gewitter im süden bis 29
grad warm sonst ist es trocken
allerdings kommen dann am freitag neue
schauer und gewitter von nordwesten her
auf temperaturen bleiben ähnlich damit
ein schöner abend